Asian stereotypes and
jokes are so played out.
It's the same shit that we've
heard for the last 50 years.
Like miss me with that.
It's so boring. It, yeah.
This point,
is it better than mirror
three two
no.
Wait, describe American
food though. I just,
I just thought of hamburgers and like
a loaf and meatloaf and mashed potatoes
and stuff. So I'm like, of course
Asian foods better than that.
I was just denied Asian
food for a long time.
My mom wanted to be Caucasian.
She wanted me to grow up as a white person
and I think I was maybe 10 or 11 when
I truly like experienced Korean cuisine.
Oh my God,
this is amazing.
What's she saying? I find a really
common cause when I grew up, you know, I,
my parents were boat people from Vietnam.
Like they wanted us to assimilate as
much as possible and not be made fun of.
So I love Asian food too.
I am, but I'm from Texas,
so I grew up in like chicken fried steak
and biscuits and all kinds of stuff.
So I fucking love marriage.
Wow.
Three, two. Wow.
My Dad doesn't care.
He's happy no matter if I'm happy.
My mom never specifically said it,
but it was almost like if I don't
bring home a Korean or a Caucasian,
which is her preference, like I don't
know if she's going to disown me.
I don't know what will she kind of push
away a little bit from me and I don't
want that. My parents,
at one point in time,
we're very happy like you need to
marry like a Vietnamese person,
but as I got older,
I understood why for them,
because it's more about we just wanna
be able to relate to the person that
you're actually with so we
can talk to them too. For me,
it's really interesting because I'm
actually married to a black woman.
I'm Chinese Malaysian,
but I grew up with a white father,
like white people were
definitely always an option,
but then you know other groups
of people, it's like, well,
we're not really sure that
they're like that. Great.
That often seems to be the case.
It's like you can date white or Asian
and and everyone else off the table for
some reason.
Yeah.
Asian stereotypes are three.
Two wow
are funny. I like, oh wait,
somewhat disagree.
We're not judging you.
Making in your head during my head is
like stereotypes are a reflection of
perceived behavior and also I write comedy
and so I'm constantly thinking of ways
to maybe subvert a stereotype to get a
laugh.
I feel like it's always dangerous though
because you never know if the joke is
going to be perceived as like,
oh they're making fun of the stereotype
or the reinforcing the stereo
tight, but even then you're saying like
the stereotype itself is not funny,
but you're some version of it is okay,
so maybe I'll move down.
See
I think I'm just like tired of like
Asian stereotypes and jokes are so played
out. It's the same shit that we've heard
for the last 50 years and like American
culture than like miss me with that.
It's so boring at this point.
I don't find it funny.
Well,
I totally understand from another
point of view how that's absolutely
inappropriate for from a personal
level. I'm not offended, I'm not hurt.
Some of them are like, yeah, that's kind
of true. What's an example? I guess?
Yeah,
actually I might move again.
You don't like for
instance me as a Korean,
like if I were to say something about
like how I feel like a lot of Koreans
behave like Koreans love uh,
k pop like boy bands.
It could be funny and it's not
necessarily an offensive stereo
but the growing up with like Asian men
have small penises and they'll all sorts
of other emasculating kind of stereotypes.
Those kinds of stereotypes play into
like why can't I be the love interest
because I have a small penis
but I don't actually know that.
And why does it matter? Well you're
talking about is like a stereotype.
It's been put upon Asians by non Asians.
If we agents want to talk about like
subcultures and Asia and like make fun of
shit totally down. Might find it
funny to see how the joke is totally.
I guess like when you say when,
when the statement is Asian
stereotypes are funny.
I'm often thinking western
stereotypes about Asians. I'm like no,
it's not funny.
Okay.
Asian people easier.
Three.
Two.
Why?
When did you say it has an easier,
I think at discounts in the amount
of work that's gone into building,
building those communities. Are
People working up towards, you know,
becoming professionals or
white collar professionals?
Like I don't think they
have Asians have it easier.
I think many Asians have
just fought harder. I don't,
I'm not saying the
other communities don't.
I just think that I think
they have earned it.
I think that part of like
how white supremacy works
to kind of like cover up is
they say like,
well if this one group of minorities is
doing well then there can't be racism in
this country.
We as Asian Americans have to understand
that we are props for white supremacy.
When we buy into the idea that all of
this stuff that we've gotten is purely
through our hardware.
I do think Asians who have an easier,
just because we're not
portrayed so negatively. Yeah,
we don't have as many like
overtly negative stereotypes
that are like thrown at
us.
You know?
I mean like you look at immigration and
like nobody's freaking out about Asians
coming into the country,
which I feel like it's just been
interesting to me to see you,
especially also like Asian Americans that
are okay with it because it's not them
right now. And that sense I'm like, oh,
we must have it easier because we're
not concerned about what's happening to
other people.
Three, two, one
super conflicted on this one.
I went to the motherland,
um,
maybe like five years ago and I thought
that it was just going to be like so
much fun and they were going to like be
accepting and for the most part they are.
But when I went there I
realized like I'm not from here.
Like it was really pretty obvious.
I mean I definitely want to connect
to the culture that I was born into,
but also a huge part of my identity
is my queerness. And in Malaysia,
Lgbtq people definitely don't have the
same legal protections if they have any
protections at all.
And so that is painful to know that
if I went back I wouldn't be accepted.
It's a funny thing that happens
when I go back to China.
Just like the feeling
that I never get here,
which is like when you walk onto a
public street you feel like you're not
identified by what you look like,
which is amazing. But that being said,
like I feel culturally I'm American,
I love being here and I think that being
like an individual with freedom is like
part of who I am in the sense that I
wouldn't necessarily fit in in China.
And I feel like so much of the time
we're like asked to be like, well,
are you Asian? Are you American? It's
like, no, like I'm Asian American.
I don't think we have to be that for this.
Is it
three, two, one?
Yeah,
it's important to me.
No, it's okay. We just want
to know what you think. Yeah,
I mean like I think I think about
this a lot is like sometimes I
get thin,
I'm Asian and then like it's kind of
jarring to being reminded than I am.
And so like
were you raised like with strong cultural
values and stuff?
I was raised,
I'm a military brat and so
even though I grew up in Korea,
it was on the military base
and so it was like an American,
a high school in like a small American
city in the middle looks song.
Me and my brother were
usually the only Asian kids.
So I remember kind of like do I want to
stand out as like the only Asian kid or
do I just want to be
another one of the kids?
I think there can be balanced in that
and that was the biggest problem I had
growing up is that I didn't know I
wanted to be American so bad. I just,
I thought I had to choose a side and
then eventually I was like, look,
both are part of going him.
But what his
further this
strongly agree part is I have a
three year old child is half Chinese,
half Vietnamese and I don't want him to
live with the confusion that I grew up
with.
For me like it actually,
I feel a lot of pain still and a lot of
grief because when we moved to the u s
and you know this was like in a time
still where you need to speak to your kids
in English, they have to just know English
and anything else will confuse them.
So my mom stopped speaking to me and Haka
and I forgot that language and we also
didn't really celebrate any
cultural traditions, you know,
Chinese or Malaysian or Chinese Malaysian.
I have no idea what that really is.
And so, um, my culture is important to me,
but I'm still like trying to find my
way back to it. Like do you grow up?
You're like socialized to fit in,
right.
And often means casting aside like
the culture that you grew up in check,
we're all experienced it to
some degree of like, hey,
should I like look into
like where I came from more?
It's a great thing if you can
be proud of where you came from.
I'm glad that we're connecting to that.
That was so fun. That was
interesting. Very, very,
can I be friends with all of the ones?
And if you strongly agree,
subscribed and let us know what
you thought in the comments below,
see you next time.